there are moments in your career that i
remember you being very angry
one of them was a bj penn fight well if
you almost stopped bj penn the round
ended
and you jumped up and punched the turn
you punched the cage
yes you remember that yes you were still
mad you need to canalize your emotion
when you fight
you need to be stoic no emotion but
there's times that it's time to use your
emotion
but to use it to propel you
to to to use it to motivate you to be
able for example to finish the round
with more energy
even though you're physically exhausted
you use that those emotion
to push yourself but the
emotion is a little bit like a fire it
can
help you cook your food but it can burn
you it's like tomorrow
it's like fear fear kasamaru said
if you have a huge ego like i i have an
incredible
ego i'm very very proud i'm a very proud
person which
helped me be a better fighter but also
it's it's an issue with sometime in life
if i use my emotion when i get hit like
i did for matt cerro because i wanted to
give it back to him right away
i didn't like to be stunned i never been
stunned in my life never
it was the first time that i got stunned
and for me it was
humiliating humiliated he humiliated me
so i wanted to give it back right away
so we can shut everybody's mouth and
you know that can say you see it was
just a little mistake and that's it
but if you use it for that particular
thing it could be a big mistake
you need to analyze it and knowing
when it's time to use your emotion you
keep it inside of you and when it's time
you let it
let it explode isn't